we're gonna begin this hour with a new
documentary that has new information
about a secret American military unit
and this is going to change your
understanding of the Iran hostage crisis
more than 40 years ago it's called
America's hidden stories birth of Shadow
Ops and it's hosted by our own Catherine
Herridge debuts tonight on the
Smithsonian Channel which has the same
parent company as CBS by the way you
remember you may remember a first
attempt to free the 52 hostages in Iran
that ended in Failure back in 1980
operation Eagle Claw well this
documentary looks at a highly secretive
army unit called the field operations
group or simply fog that was tasked with
planning a second rescue attempt for the
first time we were hearing about the
efforts to find the American hostages
from former members of that team here's
a preview
we want them to take down the
communications in in Tehran Shepherd
Square was the key location for the
communication we would go into the top
of Shepherd square on Little Birds be
able access the building and work our
way down to the control center and have
control of the radio and television
throughout Tehran and how important was
it to have that sort of command and
control of the airwaves if you control
the airwaves you can control the city so
we hope create enough confusion in order
to get the hostages up whether it's
psychological operations or basically
telling people to stay off the street
you know it would help protect the force
we practiced we never had really good
success we always calculate our kill
rate at about 25 percent 20
25 no 25 of our people on 25 of the
hostages
well that team never launched that
mission and Iran released the 52
hostages on January 20th 1981 444 days
after the crisis started Catherine joins
us now uh Catherine you're so good in
this documentary you're exactly the
person to tell this story and it's
really the story of the birth of Special
Operations which is a major plank of our
International Security today talk about
what happened in 1980 and how it got us
to today well when you think about the
failure to rescue the American hostages
this was a humiliation for the US
Military and for the Carter
Administration but the story people
don't know is that privately and almost
immediately President Carter authorized
planning for this second Rescue Mission
and they drew the best of the army
Special Forces to execute that mission
and you're going to hear from their own
lips the story of how that unfolded 40
years ago it was fascinating to me I
like how they said it's a combination of
innovation and courage there's no room
for error when you're doing these kind
of missions and I was surprised that
they were talking about it now why do
you think they're talking about it now
all the years later and do you think it
still matters today it makes me think
there's still things going on Catherine
that we don't know about give me a wink
wink on that well what they told Ben did
but oh okay what they told us is that
it's possible to tell this story this
brief window Between 1979 and 18 1982 is
because so many of the records have been
Declassified and this army unit was only
around for a short period of time but
they pioneered this revolutionary
Playbook that combined intelligence
gathering and Operational Support for a
strike force we go up into the skies and
you can see how they gathered
intelligence from shortwave radios
walkie-talkies and then on the ground
they took that intelligence with other
capabilities
to locate a Target in this case it was a
kidnapped American General in 1981 and
this was out of the box thinking and it
was completely different from what the
CIA was doing and you end up talking to
him but you know when I was watching it
it made me very proud for what they did
back then without the technology that
they have today and I thought if they
did that back then imagine what they're
doing today Catherine Herridge well
that's right and you think about this
chapter I think it really changes your
understanding of the Carter presidency
that despite the humiliation of that
failed first rescue mission that he was
willing to authorize a second rescue
attempt when the conditions were right
and you have this Elite army unit around
for just a short period of time that had
the courage to lay the foundation for
capabilities that have only improved
over time to give us I would say the
most elite fighting force in the world
and it's it's an inspirational story
a group of patriots who came out of
Vietnam who always put the country and
the mission first it's like their lives
at risk yeah to do that every time yeah
it's a wonderful documentary Catherine
thank you very much for being here the
documentary again is America's hidden
stories birth of Shadow Ops and it
premieres tonight at 8 Eastern on the
Smithsonian Channel